the moment i remember on my first test
ride on cruise that i'll never forget is
we're driving down 101 and kyle says oh
a shadow let's see how the car handles
that
and it was like oh [ __ ] kyle
hey this is michael cybel with dalton
caldwell and today we're going to talk
about what does it really mean to do
things that don't scale this term was
massively popularized in a pgsa from
2013 but it was advice that he'd been
giving yc founders for a really long
time
but delton it seems like a lot of
founders get this confused doing things
that don't scale is doing something
that's provocatively
manual on your part
where you the founder
does a thing personally
and that isn't counting on a lot of code
that you're writing or scalable
processes
um to run what how you think late stage
companies are run might help for us to
give some examples let's give examples
um
reddit so day one reddit
exists site
no links
no users no users blank page but like
the click a button to submit a link
what do you do if you're stephen alexis
so the scalable solution
is you first launch subreddits
then you run ads to recruit people to
come sign up for reddit on different
topics and then hold on then you would
hire an influencer you would get you
have an influencer strategy to get
influencers on various topics to come
moderate the subreddits
okay and so the day you launched you
have this big splashy launch with
hundreds of thousands of signups right
that scales
that skills what steve and alexis did
was
they made a little tool that allowed
them
to submit a link
the same thing that normal users used
but they had a little extra field where
they could put in a username and they
just started inventing different
usernames and submitting links like them
so day one when they emailed this to
their like six friends it looked like
there was a page full of users when in
fact there were two users
and i remember
steve tells two stories the story the
first day someone else other than them
submitted
which was not day one
and then he tells another story where
like i think he went out and he got
drunk
and the next morning he had forgotten to
like load up this morning's fake links
and he thought the site would just be
blank and he was like so pissed himself
but then he opens up the site and it
looked like there were enough other
people submitting links that the site
wasn't blank
and then he was like that might have
been what 20 or 30 people right and he's
like oh wow like
major milestone
what was the door dash story adult well
look
when you when you think about something
like food delivery um you imagine a
scaling you want to be doing hundreds of
orders a day and so the way the founders
got started
was they just did all the deliveries
themselves they didn't have to hire
anyone or build a driver app or recruit
drivers if someone made an order
via doordash if some miracle happened
and someone made an order
um
the the founders would like drop
everything and go deliver the food
[Music]
right
that was actually how they got started
go ahead what's so cool about that is
that you know one of the other topics in
this essay is like delight your users
right
well the easiest way to delight your
user when you're doing food delivery is
you deliver yourself right you race to
the freaking restaurant you make sure
you get the right thing you throw in an
extra you deliver it yourself you say
thank you they didn't have to deal with
managing a driver network motivating and
it's like
think about all the other ancillary
benefits where
they got to see why it was hard to do
the deliveries they got to talk to the
restaurant owners personally and develop
a relationship with them they got to
talk to their users they'd be like hey
here's your burrito
i'm the founder of this company
do you like it
would you order again isn't that funny
like could you imagine a more lower
status thing than
of course not but that's why it was
awesome it was not scalable it is in
present day if you order from door dash
tony is not going to deliver your
burrito
or he might statistically he still does
this sometimes i'm sure everyone says
he still does this to this day the
founders still do deliveries um
but like that was not a scalable
strategy but man that's how they got off
the ground
i think the last example um you know in
light of cruz you know cruz this week
allowed any star to allow the general
public to drive in a driver free safety
driver free driverless car
and
i remember when cruz was in yc
and the v1 of the car the v1 of the
driverless car kyle and his tiny built
team built in three months
they retrofitted an audi
to call it driverless would be
an overstatement there were a couple
things i remember one there was a big
red button on the floor and the driver's
seat and kyle never explained what that
button did
but it was clearly important and very
easy for him to reach
um number two it only works on the
highway number three it was basically
adaptive cruise control like it was
basically cruise control that stayed in
your lane it wasn't more fancy than that
and then number four the moment i
remember on my first test ride on cruise
that i'll never forget
is we're driving down 101 and kyle says
oh a shadow let's see how the car
handles that
and it was like oh [ __ ] kyle
out of everything i was looking out for
like curves other drivers signs
i didn't know that i should be afraid of
the shadow
and that was v1
that was v1 and and google had cars on
the road
retrofitted with all kinds of fancy
equipment at that time and kyle had his
audi that couldn't deal with shadows
that's how it starts
[Music]
so why don't you talk a little bit more
viscerally dalton what is that you know
we've given some examples but give us
more on what do you think the life and
the job of a ceo in these stages and
these do things that don't scale
pre-product market for stages
yeah i think
in the do things that don't scale
philosophy
the job of the ceo and the job of the
co-founders is to do
the shittiest worst
low status work you can think of it's
the opposite of whatever your mental
model when someone says the word ceo and
you're like oh wow ceo
visionary you know you know powerful
it's like no like you're like doing the
[ __ ] work
yes and you've got to learn to love and
embrace the [ __ ] work
that is your job at a pre-product market
startup is
to actually make everything happen
and to be personally accountable for
making the entire system run end-to-end
and we just see so many founders
that think it's their job to be like at
the late stage you know they're
emulating
what they think elon musk is like or you
know
mark zuckerberg or something
but
when you're a really small startup it's
the exact opposite in every way
this thing that came to mind is you know
we talk to a lot of smart people who
aren't cut out to be founders
i think the reason why is that smart
people don't tend to want to do [ __ ]
work
it's like a special kind of person who's
smart
but who's like no no no like i'll get in
my car and go pick up that order or like
no no no like i will hand figure out how
to build this horrible motor to move a
car wheel like i'm gonna get into the
guts
and
most smart people just don't want to do
that especially if they can get jobs
where they don't have to think about how
much for most of our founders their
actual job
is
answering customer support emails
and talking to angry i write i rate
people that hate them and are like
i hate you
like you're dealing with like
up close and personal feedback cause
you're a tiny startup right there's no
one else to yell at and so every time
like doordash screwed up an order
the founders of doordash would have to
be like i am very sorry
uh we will do better
like you're the first lives
i love that i love that because
sometimes founders want to put other
people on the front lines and it's like
like no like you are the front lines but
it's more scalable again and again we're
not trying to be facetious it is more
scalable if the if the founders could
spend their time on other tasks right
that's more scalable but if you're doing
things that don't scale you embrace the
suck
right you give it a hug you're like yes
i love doing this horrible work
um
that is what actually doing things that
don't scale is
well and then to your point you learn
you learn what other people are
unwilling to learn
so you build a better product
and so you serve your customers better
and especially when you're dealing with
incumbents you better believe that their
senior management team
isn't out on the front line so whoever
is developing the product there
they have some researcher or some
outsourced person doing all this
customer surveys and crap
and if you're on the front line you'll
learn 10 times more than they will what
about your friends
who are making fun of you because you're
doing this [ __ ] work
you tell your friends what you're doing
you know they work at google they get
free food and free laundry and google
bus
and they're like what are you you're
you're you're hand delivering food like
your your hand adding links to your own
link sharing website like
like how do you get over the know what i
was telling you like you are an idiot
that's not how it works i know how it
works i work at google
well you you are an idiot because you
started a company no just kidding um
like this is what comes with the
territory friends like like if it were
easy to start a company and anyone could
quit their job at google and just
magically have product market fit and be
successful way more people would do it
like how many googles are there in the
world not many
and it's because there's this
um
this stage screens out most people
because it sucks
right
it sucks hard and so most people look at
this and they're like i have to do what
and then most likely i'll fail and i'll
go broke whereas i could keep
my high status job
this screens everybody out this is why
they're not more successful
founder like the reason why there's not
more startups in the world is not
because there's lack of good ideas or
innovation or i would argue even funding
it's basically there aren't enough
people
that really want to do this stage of the
startup and are good at it
now let's talk about this kind of we
keep on bringing google let's go with
this phenomenon i see so many young
founders basically saying like before i
start a startup i need to work at a big
company that's where i'm going to learn
how to do it
do you think google's going to help or
where how do you think it helps and how
do you think importance because i think
it's it's more nuanced than just one or
the other to set the scene
if you've ever interviewed for like a
programming position at google or
facebook or amazon a lot of what they
have you do is design algorithms that
ideally are scalable algorithms
right like ideally you're not you know
bubble sorting on the whiteboard um
during during your interview at google
right
and so it gets ground into you during
the selection process that your job is
to design solutions that scale
and when you're inside of a big tech
company
you
you're rolling things out to millions or
tens of millions of people and so you
you're you're beat into your head that
you only scalable solutions are good
solutions right like if facebook had
some new feature
but it required them to buy a hundred
times more servers which would bankrupt
the company guess what would happen to
your bright idea
can't do it it's got to be more scalable
right or like so every every single
product idea or feature that you build
inside these companies is viewed through
the lens of scalability and rightfully
so you still with venus yes now this is
what's funny if you think of these jobs
as training for startups
is that now you've had deeply ingrained
into your brain what i would argue
is not helpful at the early stages this
is helpful when you make it to late
stage hallelujah right but the early
stages you just got immersed in a
culture
that is not helpful versus if you never
worked at one of these companies and you
just like graduated college no one ever
told you to worry about scalability
you're like yeah cool whatever like
you know i wrote the algorithm with a
bubble sort that's okay right like like
you've never been yelled at by your boss
because you came up with unscalable
ideas
you want to be trained at doing just
enough as opposed to doing perfect job
and like the startup needs to do just
enough and google needs to do way better
than just enough and i think that like
what's hard for me is that sometimes you
see those founders and they can't launch
they're like oh something's broken or oh
a customer didn't like this and they
just like cannot bring themselves to
launch because it's not perfect well
think about it if you're at google and
you launch a new feature or if you're at
facebook and you launch a new feature
and it doesn't scale like if it doesn't
work
that's the fail like congratulations you
suck and your team sucks right like and
again they're not wrong
but like the all the incentive structure
is set up to not launch a feature
that is not scalable this is where that
scalable word comes in right you're not
helping the company so one thing i think
is helpful is like how do we help
founders prepare their minds for this
zone
and
we're telling you it's going to suck
we're telling you to do things that
people are making fun of you we're
telling you that you might have to live
in this spot
for a while before things start looking
better i think that the big challenge
the founders make is screwed up
expectations
like the big challenge is that founders
think i launch it and then it's gonna
work
and i really wish founders went in with
the mindset like
i don't care if it takes two years to
work like like how do you set your mind
up so that you're immediately not
disappointed
because i think that it's like you know
we talk with somebody all the time
maintaining motivation is like three
quarters of this game
i i think this is a great question and
it's funny how much
the questions
like if someone got to spend time with
us michael you know say say someone went
to dinner with us what they want to ask
us about
is like
you know i know with it i know exactly
what people would want to talk to us
about
but usually what we
usually what you should be asking us to
talk about is like
emotional well-being and maintaining
motivation and dealing with high stress
situations and dealing with criticism
like a lot of people aren't prepared for
people on the internet criticizing them
it's hard right and so it's funny how
much what people think expertise
like what they think they want help with
and what they actually need help with
are not the same thing yes and think
about how many startups that we fund die
basically as the founders run out of gas
and get sad and want to go back to their
jobs at google because this was not what
this was not what they thought it was
man motivation i don't think motivation
is about how shitty something is
right like i think it's about how shitty
did you think it was going to be when
you started
i think that's what screws your
motivation it's like how should you
think it's going to be when it started
that's why i mean honestly when i do
talks to college kids now i'm just like
this life sucks like this is the first
thing out of my mind's like this life
sucks
it's like getting punched in the face
every day
and like real face punch like not like
fake it's like you ever get punched in
the face you remember that [ __ ] for like
the rest of your life
this is like no i mean to this day i'm
sure you do too man i have like bad
dreams about my startups i still have
like it's not like we're we're insulated
from this this was hard this was like
the hardest [ __ ] we ever did yes by far
and we probably will ever do
so i mean to kind of wrap this up right
like
this idea of do things that don't scale
one it's going to be counterintuitive
two expect people around you to not
understand
and to actively think you're stupid like
not just not understand but actively
tell you
you're being an idiot like why are you
delivering burritos
like what on earth are you thinking like
you're making them like they'll like
stage an intervention for you you're
screwing them your friends will come
together they'll set you down and be
like what are you doing man
this is a mistake this is not what you
should be doing um
expect it to look way different than
what your larger competitors are doing
now
expect to look way different and expect
yourself to be the primary actor
you're not acting through others you are
the doer anything else to add though
to wrap this up
i think if you look at other companies
that raise a lot of money you're
inclined to copy that strategy
of what they're doing so again if you
see someone all these companies are
doing i don't know 10 minute delivery
right like that's the hot new thing and
so they're like oh this company raised
50 million i better raise 50.
do things that don't scale is cool yeah
not for you go do one delivery
like when i see people fail a lot
it's that they they want to get a
thousand customers and they can't get
one
just being able to say
one
we have we've delivered one burrito
separates you from the pack
yes and so again maybe this is this is
an inspiring thing
actually doing something
is much better than average
congratulations you're in the top half
of stoddard founders if you can get out
of your own way enough to do one thing
to extend that
and if you can get that person to do it
again
they enjoyed it enough the first the
customer enjoyed your product enough the
first time that they're gonna use it
again
because that's the other question oh we
have a ton of users like oh like how
often do they come back it's like come
back are we supposed to be looking for
we're supposed to be measuring that was
that on the test i didn't study for that
one
it's like well
okay
all right that's two things that don't
scale don't just take our word for it
though the essay is online
you can read it and trust me you'll get
a lot of out of it if you just go read
it so google search do things that don't
scale pg and i'm sure you get the link
on the top alright see you later dalton